great so hi everyone my name is will and
I'm going to be talking about graph
analysis of Russian Twitter trolls so
the the idea here is really to provide a
sort of an overview of graph databases
and specifically near for J which is an
open source graph database but in the
context of a specific data set with data
on Russian Twitter trolls and will talk
a bit more about what this data set is
in a minute so this is me I'm a
developer at near 4j near 4j is an open
source graph database curious how many
people have heard of near for J or using
here forge a few folks okay okay cool so
I work on the developer relations team
at neo I spend most of my time building
integrations so I don't work on the core
database itself instead I work on
tooling around the database making sure
you can use neo4j with your favorite web
development framework there's tooling
for moving data back and forth between
different processing frameworks things
like that my current project is working
on a graph QL integration so we know who
wants to chat about that I'd love to as
well but I also run what we call the
near fridge a data journalism
accelerator program and the the goal of
this program is to provide some
technical resources folks like me to
work directly with data journalists who
are working with datasets that are often
complex and connected data that lend
themselves to be analyzed with a graph
database so the the project we're going
to talk about today is one of the more
recent projects that I worked on as part
of this data journalism program with
neo4j and this was a project that we
worked on with a team at NBC News
specifically looking at Russian troll
data and there are a few articles that
they published been Popkin was the the
main writer that we worked with on this
but first of all let me give just sort
of a brief overview of what a graph
database is and talk a little bit about
neo4j specifically and then we'll dive
in to the data a bit so since we're
talking about Twitter data I think the
best way to sort of summarize here for J
is in the form of a tweet so here's an
ear for J and 140 characters I guess I
could use 280 now I can expand this a
bit but near for J open source software
that stores and queries data as nodes
and relationships using the cipher query
language with index free adjacency okay
so let's let's dissect that a little bit
so first of all in year 4 J is is open
source that means all the codes on
github you build from source lots of
lots of ways to get to get started with
it
near Forte is primarily a database so
it's a transactional database focus on
data durability so when a transaction is
committed that data is safe and near 4g
allows us to store in query our data as
nodes and relationships so we use what's
called the property graph data model
with near for J so nodes are the
entities in the graph and relationships
connect them we can store arbitrary key
value pair properties as attributes on
both nodes and relationships this data
model comes from another data journalism
project called the paradise papers so
this was a leaked data set of offshore
corporations and the people connected to
them there are lots of influential
people and companies that were found in
this data so this made lots of
interesting headlines as well and the
data journalists that we're working with
this data used near for J to make sense
of this data and this is the data model
that they use so here we have entities
these are the offshore corporations
they're connected to officer nodes
either
actual people that are either a
shareholder beneficiary of the company
and then we have intermediary nodes
these are the law firms that registered
these legal entities on behalf of the
officer and they're all connected to
address nodes so that's the basic data
model for this example okay so on to the
next part of our tweet here so we're
storing and querying our data as nodes
and relationships using the cipher query
language so at the top there is an
example of cipher you can think of
cipher as sequel but for graphs so
cipher is very much about pattern
matching so in that first match
statement we're expressing a graph
pattern with this sort of ASCII art
notation so nodes are within parenthesis
relationships within brackets and then
we're doing we're doing a where
predicate filter here so you can see we
have some similar semantics to what you
would see in sequel and what this
pattern is saying is find all of the
address nodes where the address property
contains Palo Alto and then traverse out
from those address nodes to find all of
the officers so find all of the people
with an address in Palo Alto and then
from those officer nodes traverse out to
find the entity nodes to find that the
offshore corporations that they're
connected to so if we were to run this
query against the Paradise Papers
dataset in near forge a browser Neeraj a
browser is like a query workbench for
exploring data in the air for je we
would get a graph visualization looks
like this so we can explore the data
visually as a graph we see a few sort of
more connected clusters in here that
might be interesting to explore but
sometimes the the answer to our question
is the result of an aggregation it's not
graph data sometimes it's just tabular
data so here's a slightly different
version of that query this time we're
doing a group by
and jurisdiction so now we're saying
okay for everyone with an address in
Palo Alto that has an offshore company
that showed up in the Paradise papers
what are the most popular offshore
jurisdictions that they use to register
those companies so the the group by its
really sort of an implicit group by so
anytime we return something along with
the result of an aggregation so here
count is the the aggregation function we
have an implicit group by with whatever
we're returning it with yeah yeah that's
a good point so so we have we have a way
to express a pattern sort of as
completely as we want to on on sort of
the left side of the officer node here
we've specified a relationship type
within within brackets so that means
we're only going to traverse this
registered address relationship type to
the right of the officer node we just
have two dashes so we're not specifying
the type of the relationship to follow
which means we'll follow any
relationship in that direction so this
this arrow here is indicating the
direction to follow yeah that's a good
point
and so similarly we've specified out
after the colon here we've specified the
node label to match on we we don't have
to specify the label and then the the
thing before the cola this becomes an
alias or a variable that we can refer to
later yeah that you're working from are
filled with errors that statistics and
an of incompleteness and the inaccuracy
would be central and it's quite
surprising to me therefore to see you
doing something that does not have that
in an intrinsic way yeah so there's you
know like
like other databases and other sort of
data operation there's a bit of data
cleaning that goes on before you're
ready to sort of insert that into the
database so so for example for address
we may have many different formats of
the address we have many different sort
of misspellings that kind of thing we've
done we can assume that we've done sort
of a pre-processing step before we've
imported the data you can get almost
clean data set but in something like
this when I think of detective
journalists I would expect that dirty
data is fundamental everything that
you're doing yeah absolutely that that's
a really big problem this this data came
from leaked documents in lots of
different formats right so it came from
reconstructed sequel dumps from a CRM
system it came from things that were
extracted from PDFs that came from
things that were extracted from emails
both manually and with automated tooling
so the there's no sort of magic tool
here to get around that that's sort of
data cleansing process that's that's a
very common problem yeah another
question No cool so so sometimes the the
answer to our question is tabular data
right so so here we want to know okay
what are the most popular offshore
jurisdictions for people with an address
in Palo Alto so because we're not
returning graph data here we're
returning scalars we get a table so we
can see that the British Virgin Islands
is the most common offshore jurisdiction
for people than address in Palo Alto
followed by Bermuda undetermined so we
have some some dirty data we're missing
some fields here
so let's talk a little bit about how we
use cipher to build applications well
typically we would use one of the The
Client driver libraries for neo4j
that we would bring into our application
the client drivers send parameterised
cipher queries basically as strings to
the database and they handled the
responses in streaming format over
what's called the bolt protocol so the
bolt protocol is a proprietary protocol
for neo4j
that we use for sending data back and
forth to to the client drivers there are
lots of benefits of bolt previously we
we used JSON over HTTP
but with bolt we have a unified type
system so one of the problems with
working with JSON and different
languages is that there's no sort of
standard type system for working with
with JSON data and then also bolt is
stateful so it maintains a connection to
the database so I only have to send
authorization once and the serialization
format is much more tightly coupled to
the database types in the database so so
that's the reason we use bold and we
have a lot of benefits there so here's
an example this is some JavaScript code
basically we're creating a connection to
to the database we're then issuing a
cipher query
this one says find me all of the
addresses that have a latitude and
longitude and then find basically every
one that's connected to those and what
legal entities are they connected to and
then here this is sort of the the
callback anytime we we get back a
records where you can back a stream of
records any time we have a record we're
adding a marker to a map and then when
this is all completed we we show the map
and close the session
so this this comes from a little
visualization tool that I built to give
you a heat map of the paradise papers
addresses so so what's going on here
well we can see that there are a lot of
addresses sort of on the on the East
Coast there's a lot of concentration
going on in the Caribbean
if I'm on the Wi-Fi this shouldn't load
here there we go and and so this is sort
of this is an interactive tool it
basically it's just demonstrating how we
build an application with with neo4j we
can explore the the Bay Area if we want
to we can actually zoom in on those
those Palo Alto addresses I will leave
that for for her your use at home okay
so so all the code for that's online
that the demos online feel free to play
around with it so cipher is an open
source query language as part of the
open cipher project there are lots of
other projects that implement cipher
different database projects different
processing frameworks for example you
can use cipher on Apache spark to kick
off a spark job ok so back to our tweet
so we said that neo4j is open source
software that stores in queries data we
talked about the property graph model
with nodes and relationships we talked
about cipher and the final bit here is
that we do all of this with index free
adjacency so index free adjacency is
this very important performance
characteristic that really separates
graph databases from other databases and
index for you Jason C means that we can
traverse from one node to any other node
that we're connected to without doing an
index lookup so what that means is it
means that the performance of
a graph traversal is not dependent on
the overall size of the data only on the
number of relationships that we're
traversing in the local pattern that
we've specified so this allows us to
scale to very very large data sets one
other characteristic neo4j that i want
to mention briefly and if we have time
we can go into this in a bit more detail
because I think this is really
interesting is the clustering
architecture for for neo4j so we can
have multiple instances of near 4j in a
cluster deployment to scale out
throughput and availability and we
basically have core servers that are
responsible for handling commits they
this uses the raft protocol for for
consensus and then we can scale out
reads with additional read replicas okay
so what are some common use cases for
for graphs in here for J well things
like personalization so real time
recommendations product recommendations
things like this are are commonly done
in graph databases things like fraud
detection working with Network and IT
management data master data management
the the list that we see projects in in
different use cases sort of grows and
grows okay so that's that's sort of an
overview of near for J and graph
databases let's jump back to our Russian
troll data so this project started a few
months ago working with with NBC News
and it started with this list of Twitter
accounts that Twitter provided to the
House Intelligence Committee as part of
their investigation into how Russia may
have interfered in the 2016 presidential
election Twitter released almost 3,000
screen names
Twitter accounts that they believed were
connected to the Internet research
agency which is a company in Russia that
has been known to operate social media
troll accounts Twitter immediately
suspended these accounts which removed
the tweets and the the profile
information from twitter.com and the
Twitter API so this meant that
journalists were not able to look at
these tweets look at these accounts to
see what they were tweeting about which
which was really of course made
journalists much more interested to know
okay what were these accounts doing so
the folks NBC reached out to us and we
started looking at how we might be able
to piece together some of this data so
one of the first things we did was look
at Internet Archive so internet archive
caches lots of websites they have an API
so it was pretty easy to write a script
to go through each of these screen names
to check if their Twitter profile page
was ever cached by Internet Archive if
it was well then we could scrape that
HTML to grab the tweet information this
was a little bit more difficult because
because it's taken a different snapshots
in time there's lots of different
versions of the HTML that we had to
write scrapers for but what that worked
so we ended up with some JSON data that
roughly mirrors what you would get from
the Twitter API and one thing that's
that's really nice about cypher is that
we can pass JSON object as a parameter
to a cipher query so this is the import
script for importing this JSON data
engineer for J basically we just iterate
over this this list of tweets we have a
list of hashtags links that are shared
and so on we just iterate over each of
those and create different pieces of the
graph so our graph model look like this
so we have tweet nodes we extract out
user into into another node so a user
posts a tweet that tweet can mention a
user extract out the hashtags as well as
the source which is the the application
they use to post the tweets URLs that
they shared and so on and this this was
okay we found I think maybe maybe
fifteen hundred tweets from from about a
hundred of the users on the list so it's
a pretty small sample and and that was
okay that was enough to get started with
but it turns out that there were some
other folks that had been collecting
tweets leading up to the election and
and just sort of saving those and
sitting on them for a rainy day and they
were able to cross-reference their their
cached tweets that they had been saving
for tweets posted by users on the House
list and they shared that with with the
team at NBC and we imported this data
from a few different sources into one
database in the air for Jay we ended up
with a few hundred thousand tweets from
four hundred and fifty four of the
accounts on the house
troll list so remember there were three
thousand accounts on the list so we only
were able to grab just a tiny slice of
what these accounts were actually doing
but it was enough to enough to dig in
and do some analysis so looking at the
data we saw I think three sort of
categories of these troll accounts one
is accounts just designed to look like
your average American citizen
so here's Leroy this is his picture so
this is sort of the stereotypical
common American another group of these
accounts were made to look like local
news publications so this is Cleveland
online bringing you breaking news
weather traffic and more for Cleveland
from st. Petersburg and the third were
actually meant to look like local
political party affiliated Twitter
accounts so this is ten GOP which was
meant to look like it was affiliated
with the Tennessee Republican Party and
of course it was not these accounts were
all operated by the internet research
agency and in st. Petersburg so okay so
so we have this data in here for J the
folks NBC had some journalistic
hypotheses that they wanted to test so
we wrote some queries to to make sense
of the data I won't go over everything
that they uncovered the the articles out
there on NBC News cover a lot of what
what we were able to uncover but here's
here's one example so here's a tweet
from from Leroy loves USA and he's
talking about hanging a banner on a
bridge in Washington DC and sort of
taking credit for that and that banner
actually was hung on a bridge in
Washington DC and what's interesting
here is that we saw a lot of these troll
accounts trying to latch on to events
that occurred in real life so you see
this this bridge between troll world and
and reality I would which is pretty
interesting to see so if we look at
tweet volume by day we can see that a
lot of these troll accounts latched on
to events that occurred so things like
terrorist attacks things like when
Trump wins the the nomination election
day certainly leading up to the election
we see a huge spike in activity so I
think the the takeaway here is that
there was a lot of attempt to amplify
confusion and division that was going on
in in reality hashtags played played a
big part in this a lot of these accounts
when they were initially created tweeted
lots of mundane things with just very
common very normal but popular hashtags
and this was done to gain visibility to
to get an initial following once these
accounts were created and then started
using hashtags that were a bit more
controversial one one interesting
account here is world of hashtags the
world of hashtags is one of the Russian
troll accounts and that account was the
first one to use the hashtag rejected
debate topics and this was meant to be
sort of a hashtag game to encourage
others to sort of suggest what our
rejected debate topics things that the
candidates necessarily wouldn't want to
talk about and we found that actually
hundreds of non troll accounts actually
started engaging with say count using
this hashtag so hashtags was were a big
wave to sort of spread this message and
interact with lots of regular users
replies were were used as a way to gain
visibility so the the top accounts that
the trolls were replying to with tweets
were Donald Trump and it's cut off here
but the second one is Hillary Clinton
and then we can see a lot of news
publications on here as well and I think
this was done mainly as a way just to
get visibility these accounts to show up
in the mentions of these very popular
one thing that's interesting is we can
look at the difference between what we
can call original content tweets these
are tweets that these trolls posted that
were not retweeting an already existing
tweets they were not replies to another
tweet they were just original content
and then we have retweets and replies
and if we look at the the breakdown
overall we can see that the the vast
majority of the tweets that we collected
from these Russian trolls were re tweets
retweets both of other Russian troll
accounts and attempt to amplify the
message but also of normal users and we
can see that some accounts so in this
chart at the top blue is retweet vol
Orange our original content tweets and
red which you don't actually see very
many of our replies and we can see that
a lot of accounts were only retweeting
and a few were creating lots of original
content this account this is the the
Tennessee GOP party account that was
very active in original content and
replies as well we can look at some of
the the sources so these are the
applications used to post these tweets
most of these came from the Twitter web
client so going to twitter.com hosting a
tweets but we saw a lot coming from
other sort of standard social media
tools things that you can use to
schedule tweets to go out at a certain
time yes so what's interesting it
doesn't seem to be that they have sort
of a a standard standard tooling to use
because you even see some from from
Android and and iOS
from from medium buffer right so that
that's one thing that that I thought was
very interesting as sort of you point
out the diversity of tools used that so
so this is more than faking a user agent
string because you actually have to use
the OAuth credentials for a Twitter
application to post that so I'm not sure
what would be involved in faking that
but it would be a bit more complex than
just faking user agent yeah when we look
at the domains of the URLs that were
shared by these accounts you see a lot
of mainstream publications that were
shared a lot of them are wrapped up in
link shorteners which we which we went
through a little bit of expanding these
but didn't do an in-depth analysis of
actually unfurling the the shortened
links but wait what you don't see is a
lot of obviously fake news that you're
seeing here so if we look at our of the
day these accounts were tweeting so this
is an UTC time we see a bit of a spike
during Moscow business hours so despite
using using some scheduled tooling to
sort of schedule these tweets to go out
whenever there's a clear spike when we
have started the day in Russia okay
those are some some sort of basic
queries that we can run once we have
this data combined into the graph but we
can use some more complex tooling to
analyze this data as well things like
natural language processing so there
there are lots of common common NLP
tasks things like like language
detection entity extraction sentiment
analysis these kinds of things and there
are lots of great open source tools for
working with these NLP tasks so we don't
need to reinvent the wheel here now most
NLP tasks are annotations where you're
taking some text and you're annotating
it with part of speech and hanging with
some sentiment something like that so
how do we annotate data in the graph
well we do this by creating new nodes
and relationships so if we were to run
an entity extraction on our tweet data
here we would create new person
organization location nodes connected to
the tweet that those entities are are
mentioned in so that's how we how we
annotate the graph after we do NLP tasks
ok so we said there there's some great
open source in LP tools how do we use
these with neo4j well near 4j is a very
extensible database so we can actually
extend the functionality of Seifer with
user-defined procedures and functions so
this is a code that's shipped to the
database we can write this in Java or
any any JVM language there's a standard
interface that we implement for these
procedures ship them to the database and
then we can call them
from cypher so we can actually embed
Stanford quarry NLP concept net tooling
things like this in neo4j that we can
call with cipher and graph aware which
is a company that does a lot of near 4j
projects they've built a NLP tool chain
that is shipped as procedures for neo4j
so here we're matching on all of the
tweets that we have in the database and
we're calling this in L P dot annotate
procedure which will then process the
the text of the tweet using in this case
Stanford Cornell P and will allow us to
annotate the graph by creating these
additional nodes to represent the result
of our NLP processing so that allows us
to look at okay what are the most common
people mentioned the most common
locations the most common organizations
that show up in this dataset and
location is interesting as we see lots
of lots of these sort of local news
accounts tweeting about events they're
going on in these in these cities we see
lots of political people and political
organizations Benton mentioned so sort
of usual usual suspects there but this
also allows us to query now in the
context of a certain location or a
certain organization so here we're
saying find all the tweets that are
talking about Louisiana and then show us
all of the hashtags that are used along
with those and what we can see here is
that these specific tweets dealing with
Louisiana are talking about certain
people so here we can see John Edwards
being mentioned and so on so this allows
us to add add some context to
to the queries when we're exploring the
data okay so another another powerful
piece of tooling that we can use to work
with this data is this idea of graph
algorithms so there are there are a few
different algorithms that are relevant
here one is centrality centrality is
this idea of a measure of importance in
the network PageRank is one measure this
is a recursive algorithm that is
relative to the importance and number of
connected nodes
give me my my importance in the network
between the centrality is a different
measure of centrality the definition of
between the centrality is simply the
number of shortest paths between all
nodes in a network that pass through a
given node so in this diagram we can see
the red nodes have a high betweenness
centrality because they're acting as
bridges or sort of connectors between
different clusters in the graph and
another measure of centrality is
closeness centrality closeness
centrality are nodes that have high
closest centrality are often highly
connected within within a cluster but
not necessarily outside of that cluster
so lots of different ways to measure
centrality and then community detection
or clustering they're not quite the same
thing but we'll treat them as the same
thing for our discussion they're
basically different oh what a way to
segment the graph to find partitions or
communities in in the graph and there
are lots of different iterative
algorithms to do this basically they all
work by minimizing modularity which is
the ratio of relationships inside the
network to the racial relationships
outside of of the cluster okay so so how
do we run these graph algorithms in the
forge a well I want to take sort of a
step back and take a look at another
Twitter analysis project from a few
years ago that a data scientist named
John Swain I was doing using neo4j
so he was looking at tweets around
popular discussions on Twitter things
like brexit things like the the climate
change debate and he had this this data
pipeline that worked worked well for him
so he would collect tweets they would go
into a message queue then they would go
into then they would go in
engineer for J then he would pull up
some subset and run some graph
algorithms in R and then those would get
dumped to my sequel so that he could use
visualizations with tableau or they
would get dumped as graph ml so that he
could use Jeffie to visualize that and
so he showed us this and and we thought
oh okay there's there's a lot of moving
parts there this this could be a bit
simpler I think right so so this was our
goal is to sort of enable the same sorts
of data pipeline but removing a lot of
the a lot of the moving pieces there and
so as part of this we wanted to enable
enable the ability to run all these
algorithms he was doing in our directly
in the database in India for J and so we
said that near for J is very extensible
we can write user-defined code that we
shipped to the database that we can call
from cipher so that became the framework
for implementing these algorithms as as
procedures so centrality community
detection path finding these are these
were the focus for them and they all
share a similar API which is this idea
of calling the procedure from cipher
either passing in the the label and
relationship type you're interested in
traversing or passing in
a projection of the graph and this piece
I think is is really really important
because what this means is that you can
define an inferred graph in cipher so a
graph that doesn't actually exist in the
data and you can run graph algorithms on
that Network and that's actually most of
the time what you want to do because
that that's actually often what you're
interested in are these inferred
relationships in the graph so and so in
graph theory there's a powerful concept
of triads or triadic closure this is a
slight variation of a triad but you can
bear with me on that so here we have a
user here who posted a tweet and that
tweet was a retweet of another tweet
that was posted by this user okay so a
user retweeted another user well there's
an inferred relationship between these
two users where one user is can be said
to have amplified the message of the
other user so that's the idea of
inferred relationships in the graph so
if we want to run PageRank over this
inferred amplified relationship we can
do that by defining that inferred
network with the cypher query and
passing that to our PageRank algorithm
so that we'd run page rank on the
inferred graph and we end up updating
those nodes with a PageRank property so
an additional property that we save
under the hood there's there's some
efficient infrastructure for running
these in parallel efficiently fetching
them out of the database and writing
back in parallel meant to take advantage
of multiple threads and the hardware we
ran some initial gonna call these
benchmarks but initial comparisons to
spark
we found that okay it's it's just as
good as just as good or better and on
similar hardware and we can do this on
on very large graphs initially so that's
great okay so if we run page rank on
this inferred amplified graph and we can
also run community detection on that
okay so we that gives us trolls that are
amplifying the message of other trolls
and then PageRank gives us the most
influential of those okay we need some
way to make sense of that data so that's
where graph visualization comes in so
oftentimes with graph utilization we
want to be able to bind the size of the
node to some property some attributes of
the node in this case we use PageRank to
determine the size of the node color is
the result of our community detection
algorithm so here we can see there are
three clear communities in the graph and
then relationship thickness gives us
some interaction weight in this case
it's the number of retweets between two
users these are the trolls yes this is
this this is a visualization of the
amplified that inferred that sort of
retweeted relationship where trolls have
retweeted other trolls and then we run
community detection on that and we see
sort of three distinct communities and
if we actually look at the hash tags
that these communities are using we can
see that the the red group is talking
mostly about more right-wing political
things the yellow group talking about
more left-leaning political things but
not necessarily positively and then this
purple group the smaller group at the
bottom is talking almost exclusively
about black lives matters
hashtags and we look at the ones that
are our most important our most central
we have the the Tennessee GOP is clearly
the most influential account within this
red group yeah yeah so the question is
if you did this on just a random sample
of Twitter accounts not would you would
you see these terms same sort of groups
emerge I don't know I don't think so I
think it would depend on your sample
right so if you there's some there's
some selection bias in our data set here
if we go back to talking about how we
actually got the data so we said that
well we got it from people that were
caching tweets leading up to the
election well we have to assume that
they were filtering for some sort of
political keywords to know that these
were political tweets so so there's some
bias and in our selection here plus
weird I mean we're looking just at the
troll accounts what I think would be
more interesting to look at rather than
just a random subset of Twitter to look
at actually all of the Twitter troll
tweets rather than just the ones that we
are pretty sure about the election
because we said we only captured tweets
from 450 out of almost 3000 so there's
there's a lot of other interesting data
out there okay and then this is a tool
that we use it's a simple JavaScript
library that is intended to work well
with an ear for Jay so we just sort of
configure what property we want to
represent node size and and that kind of
thing okay so so the the NBC
team they wanted to release this data to
the public after they had published a
few stories because they wanted this
data to be out there so that anyone
could sort of dig in to the the piece
that they were interested in so on
February 14th they released this dataset
both as CSV and then also as an ear for
J database and then two days later the
Mueller indictment came out and the
Mueller indictment specifically names
the internet research agency and some of
its employees for operating troll
accounts but it also specifically names
to Twitter accounts that show up in our
data set specifically specifically this
big central one right here is named in
the Muller indictment the Tennessee
Republican party account and then
another account that's named is called
March on Trump and they found that it
was actually arranging actual events
that occurred in the US so the Mueller
diamond also lists hashtags that were
commonly used that show up in the
dataset so altogether I think there may
be about 4,000 tweets in our dataset
that are relevant to the the Mueller
indictment so this was a fun project to
work on
you know I I thought the the piece about
amplifying the message with retweets
within the troll network was interesting
the the biggest challenge with this of
course was data availability because all
of these tweets had been removed from
from the Twitter API it was of course a
challenge to to get those but it was it
was a fun project to integrate them and
work with them in India for Jay
so if you want to play around with this
data you can do that using neo4j sandbox
so sandbox allows you to spin up a bunch
of different near 4j instances with
different datasets pre-loaded this
Twitter trolls data set is one that's
available on in the air for JCM box okay
so that's that's all I have to say about
Twitter trolls so I can take some
questions if no one has any questions I
would love to talk about the clustering
model in the air for J but I'll pause
for some questions yeah webcast it seems
like telling us what happened you're
telling the bad guys how to avoid being
so easily bellman expert are you
concerned about them learning what they
need to do differently so as to cover
their tracks they want to do this again
yes so the question is sort of aren't
you aren't you pointing out how to
uncover trolls in the future so they can
sort of learn from their lesson to not
be detected going forward so so no and
and the reason why is because if you if
we go back to sort of what was the what
was the origin or sort of the initial
filter for us to look at all of these
tweets is that we were given a list by
the House Intelligence Committee and
Twitter provided this list to the House
Intelligence Committee and Twitter
presumably has some methodology that
they use to identify these accounts
looking at
I don't know IP addresses or something
like that and Twitter has said
absolutely nothing about the methodology
they used to identify those accounts so
I I would say that you know that's
really sort of the the methodology that
got them identified in the first place
is however Twitter identified these
accounts and we don't really know what
that methodology was you be inspired to
use ten times as many false accounts the
next time I'm 100 times in 20 accounts
so ask me flustering less obvious and
the connections
well well again we don't know sort of
what Twitter's methodology was for
identifying these counts in the first
place so there's there's little
information available out there on sort
of how they actually determined that
these were the Russian control accounts
and presumably there's some cooperation
with the Intelligence Committee going on
and sort of with with Mueller's group as
well so I I think because we don't we
don't know that I don't think there's a
lot of you know a chance that this is
helpful information for for future
trolls
there was in fact this if we if we
didn't have this initial list to dig
into this project would not be as
interesting because you can you can
argue sort of all day long whether or
not someone is an actual troll account
actually one of one of my co-workers and
I were talking about this project and he
had had mentioned sort of another
citizen journalist who had identified
hundreds of Russian troll accounts and
in my coworker looked at the list
and one of the accounts on the list was
a good friend of his sister not a
Russian troll so you know I think
Twitter there's a lot of I did a burning
pile of garbage comes to mind right that
goes on on Twitter so this this list is
really what made this project possible
and interesting without of it
without it I think it would be sort of a
lot more supposition type things yeah
that's that you repost by copying and
pasting rather than retweeting I don't
know why that is the case because I'm
not really tweet the tweeter mm-hmm but
did you try to detect that kind of
behavior also or was there any of it
because retweeting is kind of obvious in
that it creates that link rather
identical content yeah so have to be
careful in the way that I answer this
because we we had data in different
formats that we used to import into our
database some of it had the clear
connection so the tweet IDs that was a
retweet of another tweet and some did
not so we we dealt with that in sort of
a data cleansing manner well
for for a piece of the data yeah yeah
it's not something that we specifically
looked for people that were copying and
pasting text of a tweet versus
retweeting it's not something we
explicitly looked at but we did to try
to model the case where we believed that
a tweet was a retweet of another tweet
yeah so so at NBC there were a couple of
folks on sort of the the data
visualization and and the the writing
piece of it and then we were doing a lot
of the the data import and a lot of the
analysis of the data and it was myself
and one of my co-workers sort of
part-time for a couple months what you
have that is on what might be done to
combat future service providers or might
better be able to detect what's genuine
what's not what kind of cross jacket can
be done how they might flag or
understand systems versions based on
stuff as it's happening
instead of
yeah so one thing that I don't think is
very clear or how it's handled on
Twitter is when you choose to report
something as spam or to block a user
that information goes to Twitter and
it's not very clear what they do to it
there are actually some some sort of
citizen journalism projects to actually
create sort of shared block lists so
that you you can sort of see other
accounts that you're like trusted
collaborators have identified as as
potential potential trolls or potential
fraud so you know I think it it doesn't
help that this data was removed from
Twitter and the Twitter API so it's very
difficult for folks to learn from from
this experience because these tweets are
not available to the the general public
and you know Twitter would say that well
that's our standard practice we
identified that these accounts violated
our Terms that they were harmful so we
removed them we suspended them and as
part of that process those tweets are
removed but that doesn't help people I
think to sort of get call it social
media literacy I guess to sort of look
back on this whole process and see what
was going on so I would argue that's
that's maybe part of it is is sort of
making these tweets that we know are
tied to the IRA a bit more visible do I
need to say that so you know the NB C
folks have talked to Twitter about about
getting this data
I work in tech I know folks that work at
Twitter it would be yeah I mean it would
be it would be great to chat with folks
about this you know I think there's not
a lot of visibility into this at this
point but yeah I would if you have
contacts I would appreciate it you know
thank you have a turnover to attend
return running so you could show
examples of the actual trolls sure yeah
absolutely yeah so so this data set is
focused on the u.s. election simply
because because of the nature of the
data that we received that is sort of
the focus of of both what was collected
and what we're analyzing but just in the
subset that we picked up there have been
journalists in Italy and Germany and the
UK that have seen things around miracles
election things around brexit things
around
I forget the the controversial political
party in Italy that was caught up in
this as well yeah and so so you can see
that these accounts were targeting not
just the US but doing this globally as
well and I think the the idea was just
sort of to spread spread chaos and
confusion as to these different
electoral processes yeah
reverse engineering what these people
were doing from the data is really
interesting and a task it looks like
they were organized in separate teams
with content experts working on certain
areas and and in other accounts were
simply focused on amplifying the message
of those content creators but they
managed to maintain walls between the
teams so there wasn't any leakage
between the Tennessee GOP in the black
lives matter thing yep and also I'm
surprised you came to the conclusion
that they used extensive automation
which the user-agent string diversity
would suggest is not the case rather
that they posted all these things
manually well I think that there was
they were mostly and again it's the
subset that we got were mostly posted
manually but we see some evidence of
you know automation as well periods of
relative emptying activity and then they
would focus on something and so there
was somebody driving this campaign yep
absolutely well so I would surprised
that George Soros was one of the targets
because he's not very well known in the
US know you know maybe 1% of the people
know who George Soros anyone anywhere
that there was a perception of funding I
think led themselves to be targets and
in this data set yep oh the things they
didn't talk about well
there's there there's actually the saw
the a few hours after the NBC folks
released this data set RT Russia Today
broadcast they had a great segments
where the the anchor was reading through
some of these tweets and and she picked
out a lot of the just sort of mundane
tweets where people are talking about
like doughnuts or something like that
and saying okay cats right yeah like how
how is this supposed to influence the
election and these are these are very
mundane and then she also zeroed out a
few tweets that were actually
anti-russia
there were a couple of them Anxi had had
to look pretty hard to find these but
there were a few that we're talking
about I can't remember exactly what they
were but something something with I
think the the DNC email hacking tied to
Russia and something like that so so her
her argument was how can these be
Russian troll accounts if they're saying
bad things about Russia which it was
very interesting looking at sort of
trolls talking about other
trolls on on broadcast but yeah so there
was a little bit of a little bit I and
really there there was a lot of content
that was that was Pro Trump and very
right-wing but there was also there were
also things all across the spectrum it
wasn't just that you know these things
were all pro Trump there was again a lot
of just seizing on emotional issues that
were just meant to you sort of
introduced chaos and introduced some
confusion and in the process and really
just inflamed people yeah and and and
looking at Twitter data in NLP is
actually you know quite a challenge
because of just the short sample size
and a lot of the the Twitter specific
thing there there are some Twitter
specific NLP tools that are out there
now that have been trained on unlock
corpuses of Twitter text data that which
I haven't played around with those just
sort of seeing them out there I haven't
seen that sort of analysis there was
someone who dug into this data set and
that there's a there's a specific
Russian emoji which is commonly used in
Russia that it's something something
like this like with multiple Chin's or
something like that that that's commonly
used in Russia that isn't isn't used so
much outside of Russia and they they
found several of these that they thought
were very interesting so something that
that kind of ties that in right exactly
yeah Twitter resident by the 2752
accounts and you analyze some subset of
that
I presumed for all we know there might
have been thousands more accounts that
Twitter wasn't able to latch on to
whatever their search algorithm was they
might not account or whatever it is
they're looking for yep
if you have thoughts on how you might be
able to use some pattern comparisons to
check Twitter accounts in general if you
had access to the full-blown database
and try to find out if there might be
10,000 more that were used and such less
frequently less specifically in ways
that they might have been part of the
effort but didn't show up on Twitter's
scan yeah yeah so so Twitter actually
amended the list just a few weeks ago
they added I think an additional 1500 or
so although that that amendment to the
list has not been made public so we
still sort of waiting for those to come
out yeah I mean I've thought about it
that there are lots and lots of people
that are looking into this now and and
you know called sort of citizen
journalism citizen activists and again
that that example that I gave of someone
who's was sure that they identified
other trolls and it was you know a
friend of my co-workers so there's
there's lots of false positives out
there I I haven't really thought of a
intellectually honest way to do this you
could you could certainly look at
building classifiers from from the data
but I think the the best way to do this
is to actually look at things like IP
logs and and that kind of information
that Twitter has access to and of course
there you know there are things like
tour and VPNs but you know that can be
accounted for as well but yeah I haven't
haven't really made a significant effort
to do that
connecting to themselves yeah retweeting
other trolls to sort of amplify the
message yeah purposely or by chance sir
accidentally how does that work I mean
so maybe maybe sort of average normal
users that end up retweeting troll
tweets that that kind of thing or people
that end up interacting with with trolls
unknowingly mm-hmm yeah I'm not sure
that's not something I thought about
she's not paying most of her followers
most
yeah so you have you have sort of a but
well and I think this goes back to when
we looked at some of the behavior that
these accounts exhibited initially was
just sort of very innocuous tweeting
tweeting very common hashtags things
that had nothing to do with with
politics and our theory as that was
largely a way for them to gain
visibility and popularity just gained
gained followers and that kind of thing
so that later on right that they would
become more likely to be retweeted if
they have more followers that that kind
of thing yeah exactly yeah you put
agents in place you have them spend
years doing nothing suspicious just as a
way sleeper sleeper Twitter spoilers
establishing cover stories agents that
will emerge endanger I haven't been
following the news today but apparently
twitter has been shutting down lots and
lots of suspicious accounts and BOTS so
I'm curious to read about that and see
if they talk about what their
methodology is and what percentage of
those they're shutting down but I know
that that's just sort of ongoing today
just heard about that briefly right
right you don't want to say how do
identify a bot because then you'll build
a smarter bottle
well okay double shift on the bikes and
then you tell us what really happened
you